RFK talking about Ivermectin I really
for the life of me even after sitting
with Joe Rogan have never been able to
figure out how anyone justifies their
stance on Ivermectin what did he say
about Ivermectin RFK said that the
reason Ivermectin was never approved was
because it would end the emergency use
authorization for the vaccines which is
just logically inconsistent they granted
the eua to monoclonal antibodies if it
were true that there were alternative
treatments like Ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine they literally could
have just given it an eua people then
make a money argument I think Alex and I
was arguing this that because Ivermectin
is so cheap they didn't want to give it
an EU and I say make that argument I'm
not making that argument I'm literally
saying for RFK Jr to come out and be
like that's the reason they didn't
approve it is because they wanted to
sell vaccines and they needed the eua
I'm like that doesn't make sense I hear
this kind of stuff all the time and no
one ever gives me a legitimate answer